[Music]
okay everybody i am so so excited today
because i am joined by tramell tillman
aka milchik from severance we're talking
spoilers for the full season here so
make sure you watch the finale first
before you watch this interview tremolo
how are you doing today man i'm doing
well doing very well glad to be here oh
yeah man i'm so thrilled to have you
here like you are seriously the standout
character in this show and it's exciting
for you just be on my show so really
honored for that now jumping into mill
check was there any characters in any
forms of media that inspired you how you
were gonna do your portrayal of
mailchick
a lot of this was
pulling from personal experiences i've
spent a lot of time in in corporate
america
a lot of survival gigs
so drawing from
colleagues co-workers and former bosses
that i've had i used that as nice fuel
to build milk check and also just
watching a myriad of performances
performances by jeffrey wright meryl
streep denzel washington morgan freeman
that really helped to to kind of find
the base
of who militech is
yeah and that's that's a great answer
too i like that you're pulling from real
life and from actors that inspire you
now
how important of a character choice was
that for you to have that mustache
you know i was a little apprehensive
about the mustache you know i have to be
honest you know it is a specific type
and
on set we call it a character in of
itself you know it's military there's
the stash you know uh it took a while
for me to to to embrace it but once i
did i you know it serves you know it's
it's a look it's a powerful look it's a
strong look it's also very specific so
it really helps me to dive into this
world the world of lumen yeah and i it's
successful take because i don't think
anyone can imagine mild trick without
the mustache it's such an important part
to the show so yeah
yeah we're really good calling that so
we actually what's interesting about
this show is we see a little bit of
flashback time with milchik for you as
an actor does the creative team let you
in on stuff the audience doesn't know to
help you kind of know what the hell is
going on even in those scenes are you
kind of even out of the loop a bit
i am i i think it's it's a little bit of
both you know they fill us in so that
you know we have the scope of the idea
but it's important to not compromise the
integrity of the show
you know and i appreciate that it's it's
stepping in the middle check man it's
it's a challenge because this is the
rare instance that i've found that milk
check knows more than tremel
right now
um so it feels a bit of like improv
where i will have an idea tremel has an
idea of where it's going
and
then i get the next episode and it takes
a total
different leap
a whole different direction so it keeps
us on our toes you know yeah that must
be thrilling too and also the different
situations they're putting you guys in
so one that really stands out to me is
with milcheck and helly in the break
room there's a couple scenes of that
that to me seems so intense was that one
of the most intense just work in general
you've done and how hot was it in there
with film lights on you guys and you got
headphones on that must have been insane
it was intense you know i i'm really
grateful uh for catherine our our props
master who was
building this incredible set and allowed
me to have time with that machine
because it's very very specific and you
know i i believe that milk check that's
his
i don't want to say his home but that's
that's a base that's a place he knows
very well if you will so i wanted to
make sure that every knob every turn
every dial the headphones everything is
very methodical
and that it's absolutely clear as to
what he's doing uh to measure and to
basically break kelly down or anybody
else that he has to bring to the room
um it's intense you know brit
lauer is such a beautiful beautiful
artist and to watch her
just crumble as we do this scene was was
heartbreaking um but also you know
milcheck had to
to negate that and really get to the
root of why he's doing this and what
he's doing this for which i had to find
the motivation behind that myself
okay so kind of going into that though
do you think in any of these scenes with
milkshake where he does some just awful
stuff to people do you think there's any
guilt in some of these moments for him
is do you think there is a sense of
guilt
he is a man of duty so i think if there
is
some sort of questioning there i think
he he aligns himself more with getting
the job done
you know
um
he
he has he has um a position that he has
to to fill
and
uh choose to to step into and
in a way it's kind of it's either them
or it's me
you know yeah i think we all have
someone to answer to and especially in
the corporate world you know that's
that's the name of the game so
um
at the end of the day milcheck wants to
keep his job and he's extremely
ambitious
so he does what he needs to do to get
the job done
yeah that that's definitely makes sense
and it's great to hear how well like
you've just know this character and like
become it on set so i think
what made everyone love mill check was
the music dance experience so
let me ask you because there's a couple
questions about that so is that the type
of scene as an actor the night before
you knew you had to film it you were
like tossing and turning are you like
ready are you like let's do this i'm
ready to let loose some dance like how
did you feel about that i mean it was a
little bit of both steve i mean i've
okay so once i found out that we were
doing a music dance experience early in
the filming season
i
was going to work i was doing
uh dance parties in my apartment by
myself
listening to some really great music uh
motown stevie wonder aretha franklin
earth wind and fire you know um to
really kind of prepare for this i had no
idea what was going to be played at that
time and no idea what the experience was
so
but i knew that this was going to be fun
and i had a wonderful choreographer who
was just a guy tara hart uh rodriguez
who stepped in
and
basically gave me points
uh if you will like each person is like
a post
and you vibe off of that post and then
you go on to the next and go on to the
next so it kind of felt like a dance-off
but also like come on this is a party
you know let's do this it's great um
but yeah of course being the
perfectionist that i am i uh was very
nervous that morning okay so what's
interesting though about that is because
i know it's different with some movies
and shows but during that scene when you
guys are actually filming it are you
hearing the defiant jazz is there any
music playing or is it silent yeah
yes yes that record played endlessly
and it is it's it's it's an incredible
song it's an incredible piece of music
um
but it's hard to dance to
yeah
not easy
um
but it was fun to do it though
yeah and i mean look all of you guys
made it look easy and looked so much fun
doing it um and then it led to
my favorite line of the season the music
dance experience is officially cancelled
now when you deliver a line like that
perfectly but
how many takes did that take with no one
on set breaking like that series five
because that's where i feel like i would
lose it like to take that seriously you
know what i mean like
i i don't think it took that many takes
you know okay at that particular moment
i mean maybe like five or six takes
maybe i'm yeah i'm investing i mean the
music dance experience in itself took
several takes because all the angles the
lights and special effects and such
uh but that particular moment
you know
i was asked whether or not i like
prepped for that line delivery and
really it just came out of the moment
like that wow that particular take
it felt just right then dropped it
dialed it
yeah i mean that's that's cool to hear
it came in the moment too because it was
pure gold for tv so that's i'm getting
just that's awesome um now
what i think is cool too so in this big
finale we get to see milchik literally
runs to the security office so
you might have broke the record for
speed caught on camera during a
television show so i want to ask you
how many times did you have to do that
run and is there like a dolly behind you
or is there a camera operator with a
handheld behind you like how did that
whole scene even happen listen steve
that
that scene was really fun because i'm a
runner
okay i figured you were so fast thank
you thank you um any scene that allows
for movement especially with mill check
was so much fun to do because he's so
rigid and stunned you know
um
so to be able to just run through those
hallways was thrilling so there was
different shots there was a dolly that
came with i was in front and then there
was some shots of me behind
and god bless
prepare a person
because that that was a dance in of
itself because
i had to make sure i had to run but i
had to make sure that i wasn't running
so fast that i run right into the camera
right right right
and then when was behind i had to you
know he had to catch up as much as
possible and just like you said he was
like he's so fast he's so bad
i was booking it i was not marking the
run at all it was a full fledge wow run
wow and i mean
given to the circumstances you see why
he's running for his life because this
is it's a big deal what's happening
right now
totally totally and that was like one of
the most intense moments of the season
and yeah it was just an awesome scene in
general and
also i think a lot of people want to
talk about is milchik and harmony's
relationship
where would you say the core disconnect
is between the two of them like what is
it that is their big difference in a
sense
i believe harmony has a a focus uh a
fixation
with mark
okay milcheck
is very
by the rules guidelines
um
detail oriented
um get get to
get to the goal right goal oriented
um and for some reason
harmony kind of veers off the track
and and
milcheck in the power that he has in in
this particular moment he does what he
can to make sure that
we stay
on course because we have quota we have
guidelines we have protocol
and so i think that's the difference
between the two of them
however or whatever
gets harmony into that path
it leads to her her demise at lumen if
you sure yeah and you know when milchex
breaks the rules we see it when he
breaks the rules he gets in trouble like
the otc
the overtime contingency you know he
broke the rules
and now he had to clean up that mess
and then he broke the rules a little bit
with the mde because mde was at 75 and
she only got 73 but he like needed some
relief
because of so much pressure that was
happening
um or mounting up so
you know every time he kind of steps
outside the comfort zone a little bit or
changes the rules
there's uh the cards come down yes and
yeah it's interesting too and i think
there's like there is like it's a
complicated character milkshake to me
and
knowing that too and how that he is in
this antagonist-esque role
do you trammell have to though to play
him see him with loving eyes or do you
honestly just can separate that and see
him as bad and be like i can still just
kind of do this
look at him with kind eyes
yeah there you go
um
well
me as an actor i love playing complex
characters
multi-level level
multi-leveled multi-layered characters
and what was fun about this project in
particular is that it allowed me
to
to bring that to milcek
um
and
in the process of
building him i didn't ever want to judge
him
you know
i think what makes him so complex and
compelling is that there is an air of
humanity to him
right um i don't believe that he looks
at lumen or himself as this negative
or bad
entity i believe that he believes in the
core principles because of what it can
offer to the world
right there is good in him
um just the way he goes about it is a
little questionable yeah
100
um
now also just with tremel being on this
set and you're being directed by a
legendary actor and director and being
with this legendary cast around you
was there anything you learned from that
and maybe even like standout moments on
the set that kind of stuck with you
you know i've been really fortunate to
work with these actors and these these
artists in general because they're so
giving and generous
and
they don't have to be
because they have the acclaim they have
the awards the accolades
and it reminds me of
maintaining humility
and graciousness and gratitude
as milkshake says
and it was also building this show in
the midst of covid
with
a little bit of the chaos that was going
on in our world and a little bit lots of
chaos that was going on in our world
um and being separated
for health reasons
it was a great reminder of trust
and have faith in the process
right um
ben was
a constant reminder
of you know just trust the work
uh trust what you're bringing to the
table
and it allowed me to continue to believe
that i'll be where i'm supposed to be
and i love that great gift yeah yeah
that that's really inspirational and
that's great to hear that that was that
treatment you got
um everybody if you haven't watched
severance i don't know why you're
watching yet but watch severance watch
jermell absolutely kill it as mild chick
here jamal i'm excited for you the show
is blowing up each day more and more
it's going to be huge and that's only
going to bring your crew up higher so i
i can't wait to see the things you do
not just in severance but in everything
so it's been a real treat to talk to you
today and i hope to talk to you in the
future
thank you likewise